who do you like on the Democratic side
who do you who you backing I saw you had
you and bread had a power meeting with
Peapod I jest yes we did I like him I
like him too
mayor pay me you know a brilliant guy
Harvard and Oxford a degrees a war
veteran a war veteran of the Afghan war
an intelligence officer and he is
politically experienced sorry about who
you're backing but both the Biden and
boo DJ you're backing both of them yes
oh I see
well we vote for president and a vice
president don't we so you think it'd be
vice president Buddha Jeff or maybe
president or the reverse he's
experienced as a vice president did you
donate money and we want to make sure
that these two get that head start I
said where did you meet Buddha judge in
Brooklyn right was there any discussion
of gay issues with Buddha judge no no we
discussed issues like what's happening
today but know nothing about sex life
that you can inform us on that mayor
Pete is up to he did anybody sorta sighs
I'm great a great taste in men he got
Chaston is absolutely charming does he
have money late you and he you know
we've been through another fundraiser
where a Pete couldn't be there and so
chastened spoke how old his chest you
know frankly I don't know he's got to be
bad for did we call him if he was first
most gentlemen absolutely we call the
woman first lady right and he's gonna be
the first gentlemen of the United States
of America and historic one
you